what's going on guys this is Rob welcome
back to geek culture explain and Black
Bolt sucks so d23 is right around the
corner and we here at geek culture
explained decided to make a predictions
video on what we think is gonna be
revealed because I gotta tell you guys
man I'm so excited for this I am so
excited for this because there's some
things that I think they're going to be
revealing here
they're just gonna be phenomenal right
we have a whole bunch of empty dates in
phase six and we're just waiting for
those dates to be filled up so here's
what we're gonna do we're gonna run this
off as a list and then we're gonna make
sense of why I think it is that they're
going to be doing these things so here's
the first thing right right off the bat
I got my notes here otherwise I'd end up
all off track you guys know how I get so
here's what I think is gonna happen
first things first I think they're gonna
announce something X-Men and Wolverine
related now if I had to choose between
the two they may very well announce like
the name of the X-Men movie and they
might give us a date but in terms of
actually focusing I think they're gonna
focus on Wolverine now again we'll talk
about why I'm choosing these things as
we get further into the video but after
announcing Wolverine there's the obvious
choice the one that we know they're most
likely going to announce which is going
to be Deadpool I can't imagine that
they're not going to announce Deadpool 3
and if I'm betting man I would say
Deadpool 3 will probably be the final
announcement it'll be like the big Grand
Puba announcement we're all excited
we're all looking forward to it so it
makes sense that they would do that now
this leads into my next choice which is
Nova and of course there's a few
different versions of Nova that exist
out there in in Marvel Comics so we'll
talk about which one it is and I'm
choosing here now my next choice here is
the Fantastic Four now for the most part
Fantastic Four was at least partially
announced during San Diego in the sense
that it was Kevin feige coming out and
just being like it's a project that
exists and we're working on it but I
think this is going to give us more
information again we'll talk about that
here in a minute but following that of
course I think we're gonna go into one
of the things that at least I want to
see really more than anything else I
don't know how likely they are to
introduce this but I think they're going
to introduce the Exiles in the Loki TV
show and of course we talked about that
during the room around them I said I
wanted to release this Theory to you
guys this is when we're doing it so
let's Circle back around to these
different things that I'm listening and
let's talk about why I think they're
releasing these and let's start really
with Wolverine so I think that
Wolverines the choice they're gonna go
with I think we are going to get
something X-Men related they're gonna
announce it in the same way they did the
Fantastic Four or something along those
lines like hey it's a movie we're
working on that kind of a thing but I
think Wolverine's gonna get special
attention and if I'm a betting man I'm
going to bet on the idea that Wolverine
ends up getting a TV series after all
one of my predictions ever been wrong
so as far as Wolverine and the X-Men go
I think they're going to announce an
X-Men project in the same way that they
announced the Fantastic Four in the
sense that like this is a movie we're
working on and like it will be here at
some point in time if I'm a betting man
though I'm willing to bet they're going
to give us something proper that focuses
exclusively on Wolverine the reason
being because he's the most popular of
the X-Men characters right it's the one
character that people really want to see
the most from the traditional X-Men
lineup and people I think are curious to
see who it is they're going to have play
the character of Wolverine now wouldn't
it just be beautiful if Hugh Jackman
came back as Wolverine yes wouldn't it
just be
would it just be lovely just lovely
I would absolutely love that alas I
don't think that's gonna happen
Wolverine was played by Hugh Jackman for
17 years the guy is technically Immortal
but he's only got so much time that he
can play the character of Wolverine
before I imagine he gets tired and wants
to play something else however Harrison
Ford also said he was never going to
come back as Han Solo until Disney
dropped a huge pile of money on his
front door so maybe that's what's gonna
go on with you Jackman maybe he does
return regardless of who it is that's
playing the character I think the big
announcement for Wolverine at d23 is
going to be that they're going to do a
TV show but this goes into the theory
video that we made about Wolverine in
terms of what they would do with him in
the MCU and I won't go super in depth in
this video since we do have a whole
video on it but the long and short of it
is that I would do a wolverine TV show I
think Wolverine's popular enough for
that it looks like they're going in the
direction of doing TV shows because a TV
show offers the ability to give us more
plot detail for characters than we would
otherwise get in a film but the general
gist of the theory video that I had was
that Wolverine has basically been here
in the MCU for a while sure he's
hundreds of years old but the Wolverine
as we know him with the adamantium bones
and that kind of stuff which they might
use vibranium instead didn't actually
come to fruition until we basically got
to Captain America and the Winter
Soldier and we end up kind of getting
this reveal where it sort of has
callbacks to that film where in the
aftermath of Captain America's perceived
death at the end of Captain America the
First Avengers and the fact that Hydra
had been secretly taking control of
Shield that one of the things that Hydra
had been doing was launching a project
called weapons plus which was their
desire to create a new Captain America
that could be used to basically
orchestrate their own campaigns right
kind of the events that we saw in
Captain America the Winter Soldier where
Shield had like giant planes with
rockets and so on and Hydra was going to
use those basically that before that
that Wolverine would essentially be an
assassin somebody they would send out to
kill people who they consider to be
opposition and they created him during
some period period of time before we got
to the modern era like that's the
overall gist of it now again the video
goes into a lot more detail in terms of
how the episodes would unfold and what
kind of things it would feature and so
on and so forth but I think that'd be a
genius way to bring Wolverine into the
MCU but moving past Wolverine focusing
on Deadpool I think it's pretty
straightforward here right I would even
go so far as to say that Deadpool might
even be more anticipated than Wolverine
which leave a comment down below and let
me know who are you looking forward to
the most Deadpool or Wolverine I know a
lot of you guys are looking forward to
stuff like Loki but let's be honest with
ourselves right Wolverine and Deadpool
are kind of at the top of our list and
so with Deadpool I actually want to kind
of segue into Loki here for a second
because I think that'd be an amazing way
to introduce him in which I don't want
this to turn into a kind of like like a
theory video where we introduce people
but let's talk about Loki and the Exiles
so the Exiles for those of you guys who
are not familiar with the team are of
course from Marvel Comics and it's
basically a team consisting of people
all of whom come from different
realities that came together as a single
multi Universal team now we know Loki
season 2 is going to heavily involve the
Multiverse and I wouldn't be surprised
if Loki season 2 focuses on him hopping
around to different realities and
potentially trying to grab people that
can help him basically eliminate Kane
the Conqueror kind of setting the stage
for what we'll see taking place during
Avengers King Dynasty when it all
basically comes to a head in Quantum
Mania which may continue what it is that
Loki's doing or at least have some
involvement or give us the other side of
the equation absent Loki in terms of
what's going on with Kang but the thing
about this is that this will be a great
way to introduce Deadpool because you
could have some Hilarious Moments could
you imagine Ryan Reynolds Deadpool
teaming up with Loki could you imagine
that a Deadpool Loki team up that's
never even happened in the comics that
would be amazing right it's just like
Deadpool and Loki team up and like
Deadpool would come up with like a theme
song for him and it would piss off Loki
to no end but it would be hilarious for
us as the fans I feel like that's just a
golden opportunity and it'd be a great
way to bring him in especially if it's
one of those things where they just want
to kind of bring Deadpool in but they
don't really want to go through like a
whole bunch of hassle on how it is that
he got here right he just kind of
hitches a ride alongside Loki he just
won't leave and Loki's like well I mean
I guess I could have some kind of use
for you and then it just kind of goes
from there I think that's a great way to
sort of kill two birds with one stone
give us a potential new team in Loki in
the form of the Exiles and bring in a
character that we've been dying to see
having said that that's probably not
what's gonna happen I don't know how
they're going to introduce Deadpool I
don't know what form it's going to take
but I think that like revealing Deadpool
at d23 it has to happen there's no way
it can't now this takes us into Nova and
the reality here is we have a couple
different options the first one is
Richard Ryder and the second one is Sam
Alexander as far as what they're going
to reveal at d23 I think the best choice
for them to reveal here is Sam Alexander
I think it's their best choice and the
reason why is Richard Ryder is cool I
don't want to Discount how awesome he is
sometimes he really wasn't cruel until
basically 2006 going forward when Dan
Abner started writing the Nova Comics
but the thing about this is Sam
Alexander has a youthful Vibrance that
the MCU is likely going to need that the
reality here is given the nature of what
we've seen in terms of immortus talking
to Sylvie and Loki and how basically
King is just a really evil variant of
himself how ominous that seemed to be
that the overall feel of Kane Dynasty
and Siegel Wars seems to be taking us
back to the feeling that we had with
infinity war and Avengers in-game that
while those movies were just phenomenal
they were dark and I think that having
somebody like Sam Alexander who's a very
young kid who basically ends up being
inducted into the Nova Corps especially
because now we can probably look at the
idea of Thanos having taken the Power
Stone from xandar the Nova Corps is just
in shambles they were probably destroyed
this is probably the noble cores on the
hunt for Replacements it's a great way
to roll Sam Alexander in that because
he's young and he's so vibrant he's
going to be able to provide a kind of
youthful happiness to an otherwise
really dark tone think of the way that
Spider-Man made you feel when you are
watching like Captain America Civil War
or you are watching Infinity war and
Avengers endgame it was a youthful
breath of Comedy into what was truly a
very very dark story and I think Sam
Alexander could do that the other reason
why I say this and it can really kind of
go either way here is because we know
that Marvel Studios is building up the
roster for the next Avengers team we
have not seen Richard Ryder or Sam
Alexander so whoever it is that they
choose to announce at d23 it will be a
fresh face it's just in my mind I think
Sam Alexander is gonna have a much
needed youthful Vibrance going into the
future of the Marvel Cinematic Universe
specifically in phase six as opposed to
Richard Ryder who is a badass but will
actually add to the darker tone as
opposed to providing a bit of a break
away from it but of course that leads us
into our final tidbit here which is the
Fantastic Four now again the Fantastic
Four was announced in San Diego I think
they're going to give us a little bit
more here there are rumors going around
in terms of who has been cast for The
Fantastic Four if I'm being honest with
you guys I think the casting's already
done I think they already know who it is
that's going to be playing the roster of
the Fantastic Four and I think they're
going to show them at d23 if they don't
if they don't show us the cast of The
Fantastic Four d23 I think
I think
bro
monumentalism I think they're going to
show us Dr Doom I think they're going to
bring out the person who is playing
Doctor Doom and here's the reason why I
say that I know like it it seems like
it's coming out of left field like why
would they show us Dr Doom instead of
the cast of The Fantastic Four the first
reason for this is because it's Doctor
Doom and I would argue that Dr Doom is
more anticipated in the Fantastic Four
movie than the Fantastic Four themselves
I think he'll be one of those instances
where Marvel actually takes a turn and
stops killing their villains I think
this would be one of the first times
that happens because of how popular
Doctor Doom is going to be the other
reason why I say that is because if the
rumors are true and you know spoiler
alert here potentially I'm not 100 sure
nobody knows until the movie comes out
supposedly Dr Doom has a post-credits
scene in Black Panther 2 which means if
that's true he's already been cast we
already know who's going to be playing
Doctor Doom and so what that means is if
they already have his character it'd be
much easier to March him out and to say
this is your Doctor Doom than anything
else now the question is if they were
going to do that if they were going to
March out Doctor Doom what's going to
accompany him because sure it'd be easy
to say okay guys like here's Dr dooman
d23 it's really really awesome and
people are like okay cool he's gonna be
the villain in Fantastic Four I think
they're gonna launch a Doctor Doom
Centric project because of how popular
he is now whether this comes in a film
or a TV show I think that what we're
going to end up getting here is some
kind of adaptation of the Books of Doom
and a TV show is the best way to do it I
really genuinely think that's the
direction that they're heading in when
it comes to origin stories we get TV
shows when it comes to everything
outside of Origins they just show up in
the films themselves and the TV shows
kind of fill in the gap of how we got to
where we are involving that particular
character those of you guys who don't
know the Books of Doom is the definitive
origin story for Doctor Doom and funny
enough we have it on Comics explain if
you guys want to go check it out because
it's one of the greatest Doctor Doom
stories ever told but with that being
said guys we're going to bring this
video to an end let me know what you
thought about these predictions and let
me know if there's anything that you
think that Marvel Studios will reveal a
d23 that I didn't list here but thank
you all for watching and I will catch
you all later
peace